hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
we're at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and
I'm really happy to be talking with
Wendy McElroy a long time libertarian
writer thinker activists most recently
the author of the art of being free
politics versus the every man and every
woman Wendy thanks for talking to us
very much happy to be here so the art of
being free let's talk about it one of
the things I find most fascinating is
you've got a whole there's a henry david
thoreau line running through this which
is the idea of like let's not waste our
time on politics what's going on with
that this is my reaction to 911 this
book when 911 happened nothing shocked
me as much I saw hold America basically
giving up on freedom I saw a police
state arise so fast that it stunned me
as a libertarian i had spent about three
decades of my life fighting for freedom
and all of a sudden it seemed to
collapse at one moment and I thought
have I wasted my life and one of the
things I asked myself was the same thing
Henry David Thoreau asked himself when
the state came knocking on his door to
pay the poll tax what is my relation to
the state and just I mean for background
he did not pay a war tax that was going
to fund the mexican war is ever american
war he basically thought it was a
cooperation with evil that if he be paid
it would support it what is my
relationship to the state I stopped
being I had two attitudes toward toward
the state one was to rail against it to
do I've been told there was an Italian
saying that if translated in english is
it's raining again pig of a government
which is to to basically just rail
against date the other one which henry
david thoreau expressed is to when he
was released from jail and went out on
on his own on a hill he basically looked
around and saw the beauty of the world
and said here inside myself there is no
state but what I you know I think that's
great i think the row it's interesting i
feel like he's his purchase on the
American psyche has been fading and
that's a real problem
because he refused to live in the world
that other people tried to build for him
or the prisons that had built for him
but what do you say with something you
know if there is a growing abuse of
civil liberties and police power what is
the role of political activism to combat
that I mean do we get into a place where
we're going to ignore the state even as
they're putting us away I don't say
ignore the state I am going to cry out
against it say I rail against it
constantly I speak out I protest and I
think that's common decency the state is
knocking on my door it's knocking in
your door there is a police state
however I think in terms I want to live
freedom I just don't want to rail
against it and I'm starting to very
creatively pursue things like
alternative currencies I'm trying to to
go into barter I'm trying to go into
agar ISM everywhere I can to avoid the
state because most of all Turo said we
should get on with the business of
living I do not want the state to be so
important in my life that I forget to
live well that's a that's a great
message and you're a part of
laissez-faire books now to which is
reinvigorated talk a little bit about
that and where's the where's the best
place for people to buy your book the
best place is lazy fair books wwl FB org
go there what lazy fairy books is about
is not merely bookselling it's about a
community we want to make living freedom
practical we want a community to be
built in forms in the in the club in
talking to me i'm online all there all
the time so it's jeff tucker we want to
be free the state is there it's going to
be a police state it's going to come
down hard on all of us we need community
well Wendy I thank you and thank you for
the most recent book as well as all the
great historical work you've done in
terms of reminding us of a great
libertarian heritage that too often is
overlooked thanks to I was I was going
to say thanks to the state school but
also parochial schools at least as far
as I know so Wendy macro thank you very
much the new book is the art of being
free for a reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie